SMDP, by the way, theres an entire
literature about semi-Markov
decision processes well beyond
the sort of scope of this lesson.
But from our point of view what's
really neat about this, and
this comes up again and
again when you use SMDPs,
is that once we define an SMDP and
the appropriate Bellman operator for
it, we can basically just
pretend that it's an MDP.
Because at bottom it is an MDP and
these expectations allow to
ground out in that in MDP.
And so we can just pretend we're
always dealing with an MDP.
And we only have to deal with
the fact that it's a SMDP.
It just works,
I take an option is just an action.
It just takes time and
isn't atomic but whatever.
I might as well treat them
as if they were atomic.
I just let it run and it comes back.
And when it comes back it will
have accumulated for me all of
the reward that I would accumulate if
I were living in the underlying MDP.
And it will discount the future in
exactly the right way after I've
taken k steps.
>> Whoo-hoo!
>> [LAUGH] Yes, exactly.
So this is a lot of sort of
equation writing and deltas and
delta raised to powers and expectations
that allows us to say, you know what?
We're still dealing
with MDPs with options.
Everything we knew before works.
>> Okay, that's a relief, I guess, that
we didn't have to throw all that out and
start afresh.
>> Yeah, and
again I mean it's actually important.
For me this seemed like a subtle
point for a long time but
it's actually not that subtle.
It's just an SMDP is just an MDP and
where we have to keep track of the fact
that our actions are not atomic and
accumulate reward and
accumulate all the transitions.
But really, that's all captured
very nicely by this expectation.
It just means we have to hide things
like the discount factors inside of
our functions.
Whereas before with the MDP we could
stick them outside of
the transition functions.
>> Okay, well then I'm not quite
getting that name, I think.
Semi-Markov decision process sounds
like it's kind of Markov but
also kind of not Markov.
>> Yeah, that's right, it's semi-Markov.
>> But this seems Markov, right?
I mean, underneath it's just a whole
bunch of standard MDP-type transitions.
>> Yeah, that's exactly right.
But what's allowing it, but
at the level of the options right,
it's not Markov because you have
to know how much time has passed.
>> I see, I see, so where, right,
the state that we end up in
could actually depend on how much time
we've spent, how much time has elapsed.
>> In fact it will, in general, right?
Because if I do it in one step I'm
going to end up in some state.
I can't reach the states that
are more than one step away.
If I take ten steps then
I can reach more states.
So the state I end up
in does depend upon k.
It depends upon how long
the option was executed.
And in general,
since beta is a probability over states,
it could happen at any time.
>> I see, so it's got elements of
Markov and elements of not Markov.
So elements of Markov include
things like well, we can
think about the probability distribution
over where we're going to end up.
It really is Markov.
But we have to be much
more careful when we
actually sum up rewards because
the time that has lapsed is variable.
And so we have to actually take into
consideration how many steps have passed
to do that.
>> Right, and in fact is
that's a very important point.
And I'll sort of point
out two things here.
One is when we have a process
that is not Markovian,
often we can turn into, in fact we
can turn basically any non-Markovian
process into a Markovian process by just
keeping track of enough history, right?
And history is, often time is enough.
Sometimes you actually want to
know what states you visited but
often time is enough.
And so we can turn a non-Markovian
thing into a Markovian thing.
And in some ways that's what
we're doing here, right?
We are keeping track of the places
that we saw in between.
But at the level of the SMDP,
at the level of the options,
I can ignore the MDP and
pretend that the SMDP is an MDP and
that these are really atomic actions.
But in reality they aren't, which is
why R and F actually depend upon k.
It actually matters how
many steps you took.
And that affects the expectation.
And in fact, if you look at R I am
actually accumulating all the reward.
So I'm taking something that's
non-Markovian because it depends upon
the actual rewards that I see,
which depends upon the actual
states that I visit.
And I'm gathering them
with me as I go along.
So that when I pop out a level it
goes back to looking Markovian again.
>> Cool.
>> Right, so an SMDP, it's an MDP and
I don't have to think about it anymore.
>> I feel like I'm getting
the kind of math of this.
But it's still, it's still
a bit of an abstraction to me.
Can we get into some kind of an example
to to practice with these ideas?
>> So yes, first I want to point
out that I appreciate the pun,
using the word abstraction here.
>> Thanks.
>> Very good, I like that.
But I think the answer is both yes and
no.
I'm going to go through an example
that I think might help you
think a little bit about this.
But I also think that actually working
out all these expectations would take us
a long time.
And it's a really good and
useful exercise,
which is why it should
probably be an exercise.
We'll let the students do it.
>> I mean, I don't know, it seems like a
cool exercise in dynamic programming and
algorithm design.
>> But Michael, you think everything is
a cool exercise in dynamic programming.
>> Well that may be, but
that's because everything is a cool
exercise in dynamic programming.
>> Yes, that's an excellent point, and
why we're going to move
on to the next slide.